Do you recommend fasting for a breast cancer patient who is in remission?
Or let's just say, for any cancer patient who's in remission, if so, for how long and how often also do you recommend 3D sonograms to check or to check for cancer as opposed to mammograms?
The second question first, definitely sonograms are much less invasive than a mammogram, which is radiation.
I'm not positive about all the technology that's involved with the 3D sonograms, but it's still sound waves, not x-rays.
So x-rays, mammograms done on that regular of a basis. I know sometimes there may be an indication to do one.
But to do regular mammograms, annual mammograms, that's a lot of radiation over time, and I don't think that's good for your cells, because that's what damages cells and radiation is one of the key things that could cause cancer.
So no, I'm not a fan of that.
The first question, do you recommend fasting for a cancer patient who's in remission?
Or a cancer patient who's not in remission? The only thing I'd say about, we'll say no to someone who's not in remission is if you, you know, you're at an edge of too much weight loss.
We don't want to fast and send somebody into a caquexic state.
But somebody who is not in that state or is in remission, there's fasting can be very good.
So we talk a lot about intermittent fasting or time restricted eating. We have multiple blog posts of that.
So in order for you to our website to get a look at the blog post on that, can a person fast?
Yes, there is some studies that are out there that show that you have an increase in IGF 1 if you fast more than 24 hours.
So we have kind of always tended to, unless you feel really spiritually led to fast more than 24 hours.
We say keep your fast at 24 hours or less. So fasting a day a week.
It was very often biblical practice to fast a day a week.
Does that make you more spiritual? No, but it's that maybe there can be some cleansing health benefits to doing something like that.
So yeah, so I typically recommend, you know, 24 hour fast, maximum.
Now I've had no understand. I've had patients that have fasted for three days. I've had patients that done 10, 15 day fasts.
I had a patient years ago that did a 40 day fast.
Now they look pretty sparse after that 40 day fast. I'm not sure how healthy that was for them.
But they did they had other reasons for doing it. So it's, you know, I don't think there's anything.
I think there's much benefit to fasting. There is there is just tons of data and out there and research on fasting.
But you can get some of the same benefits doing a, you know, a modified fast.
And so look at the information that's out there on our website about that.
But there's certainly I don't think any downsides to doing a fast.